and you know it'll be like an actor from
Asia you know well I want to rumble Jack
breakfast
[Music]
um you know the James Bond novels
written by Ian Fleming like the original
ones right so they're written back in
about seven years ago was the first one
Casino Royale remember that one yep yeah
um they're all being Rewritten now oh no
please don't tell me it's too late in
order to protect modern readers who
might be triggered by some oh no oh man
we're gonna do the King James version of
them
is he gonna is he is is James Bond Gonna
Be Like A different race it's gonna be a
non
-bies boy
no like we
AK because I feel like those when when
written and adapted for screen have
already at those moments in time taken
on Modern like uh who's getting who's
getting who's getting pissed off when
they read octopussy yeah that's crazy
you know what I mean like who's going oh
my God Octopussy what was the premise of
octopus marine biologists whose uh idea
is it some woke ass [__]
we have an estate though because the way
that I was thinking I was like is that
[__] dead in Fleming no but they
have an estate that control his family
control they they have approval so like
when before Daniel Craig was chosen as
James Bond they have approval oh like to
say like yes no because when I look at
it through the lens of I love the
original and I don't want to touch
things like you don't [__] go to the
Mona Lisa and start scribbling all over
that [__] right you're like you make a
new one that's the way it is if I look
at it through that Lance I'm like don't
[__] touch those goddamn books
they're perfect but if I look at it
through the lens of cha-ching and I'm
Ian Fleming I'm like oh you're gonna
rewrite it for me and I make more money
and pay me more okay everybody go crazy
yeah and again rewriting is not
necessarily like change the plots or
anything like that it's like hey drop
the end bombs and say black drop the
visit
again like I said who says that what
version are you watching I'm talking
about the double seven it's wild we're
talking about the same funny books but
that's like that's like rewriting
history that's like that's like changing
like Huck Finn and like all the other
Classics
they're just Banning it oh yeah that's
different this is so that it doesn't get
better is there anything like I have a
question I think Bart's right in the
aspect of hey either you guys get all
your books banned or we can rewrite them
and make money
yeah because that's his next got a
question guys how many racial slurs does
007 use again don't take the film
adaptations no of course of course in
the movie I'm talking about in the book
did he say something mean to Baron
Cemetery so for example I didn't know
there was an n-word in that book did he
did he call I'll drop a [__]
listen here you little chick
I'm not throw your goddamn hats at me it
wasn't Michelle yo the first Asian uh
Bond girl yeah wow
and I think in the first in the first
version he called her [__] really yeah
I have no idea
he's like both James how old nothing
surprised me I can't resist a good chick
stupid
work is set to be republished in April
making 70 years since Casino Royale the
first book in the series uh Ian Fleming
Publications limited commissioned a
review by sensitivity readers leading
many novels in the series to be
Rewritten that's a horrible committee
sensitivity readers sorry that's a
horrible sensitivity even like it's like
a committee of blue hair [__] oh yeah
I get my feelings hurt like crazy you're
higher yeah
my boyfriend hates me you're high
I have no friends you're higher your
name's Janice you're hired yeah hey it's
who used to be a hall monitor me you're
all hired you you're you is it is a good
point though it's like when you think of
these things changing it isn't always
that they're being regulated against it
is the ultimate say of whoever wrote the
book to be like yeah I would like to
make more money yeah so it's true that
you can't really get mad it's they're
the ones going oh I can't be in these
stores or on these platforms unless I
change I'll change yep it's true is
there any examples of just problematic
stuff that they say in there it
literally says like each book will say
it out loud read it and we'll make an
announcement in character
and we're in a British accent just so I
can kind of get a better feeling and
then don't drop the r like leave it
there what does it sound like then I I
don't know
he only speaks Korea
so it says each book will now come with
a disclaimer this book was written at a
time when terms and attitudes which
might be considered offensive by modern
readers were commonplace why do we even
have to write that is that like duh you
stupid [__] I feel like people that's
the thing is are stupid [__] you can't
blame them what about John Steinbeck
stupid [__] reading whole books I don't
think yeah what kind of [__] idiots
reading a book but you think I mean I'm
also guessing they're sitting on the
sidelines and they're looking at things
like Casablanca getting banned and
they're like oh yeah yeah they're it's
preemptive it's preemptive yeah yeah
wait Casablanca is getting black yeah
you remember when uh yeah everything was
just getting attacked because if it had
any concept of any type of racial I mean
what's wrong with Casablanca because if
the but isn't how he speaks to the woman
that's why no Cosmic there's a there's a
also a black kind of helper oh I don't
like this catering to the lowest common
denominator [__] well I I was like
putting like in front of every car you
have a [__] sticker don't stand here
when it's moving
oh you stupid [__] don't give the
committee more ideas but have you
noticed though it's all
all the movies about
like them being misogynistic allegedly
or like against black people but have
you have you noticed nothing about
Breakfast at Tiffany's all right ever
never they'll never fix that they'll
never fix that's okay to take people's
eyes back yeah yeah yeah see that was
the Mickey Rooney right yeah yeah
I was like oh yeah that guy's Asian that
put us forward there's people still
people still think that's an Asian guy
that's why what's the name of The
Walking Dead porno that they spoofed and
then they couldn't find an Asian porn
why are you asking us like they got a
white guy they tipped his eyes back it
was evil angel produced it damn they
actually came to a show of mine during
that whole time dude you just put us on
game and you you acted like we're all
supposed to know good I did I'm sorry
it's like me saying you guys all have
dick here well you don't oh sorry
Walking Dead I don't know how they did
that one of my favorite movies you don't
think it's a deep cut they taped their
eyes back and I'm actually okay with it
which one uh kickboxer you know Tang PO
is actually Armenian really oh yeah yeah
that's cool yeah that's cool right he's
actually not right they they taped back
tombow's [__] eyeballs now that you
say that another classic movie did that
too Remo Williams
his master was Korean but he was a white
played by a white guy and they kept his
eyes back and they put all his makeup on
and it was so good nobody knew just wait
guys like 56 years from now maybe we'll
start being like hey you can't do that
and then everything will get canceled no
or maybe we'll be we'll be a white guy
and no one will know
because it's reversed yeah like they
made Walter with Roundup they tape our
eyes up yeah
hi my name is John yeah we play white
dudes that'd be cool would you like our
Lumberjack breakfast
it's a white term
we're gonna say white phrases and you
know it'll be like an actor from Asia
you know I want the rumble Jack
breakfast
[Laughter]
I love how it's like 20 years from now
and the technology is so better
so this is what we gotta do we gotta
remake Casablanca but we play all the
roles and we all be white people and
then we just open our eyes really big
and with someone holding our eyes with a
little slight Asian accent it's called
the Casablanca
dude I'm gonna get canceled my name is
Jesus Rodriguez
Casa brancas
we just gotta remake all the movies that
got canceled but with Asian actors
that'd be hilarious then it'll work we
do a mice and man
um so so let me wait to not make any
profit
dude I think it's gonna it's gonna crash
so for example
the mention of ethnicity for many Side
characters has been removed in one
passage where Bond knows the ethnicity
of a Barman in Thunderball now as I
mentioned in Goldfinger the ethnicity of
the race of the drivers in the second
world war Logistics unit the red ball
Express have um had many black
servicemen
but now the race isn't included at all
they're just referring to them as X
drivers so isn't it worse to like erase
all black people completely out of the
book is it is it worth it for 50 years
from now you know if it's not plot maybe
it's just not plot relevant yeah in the
new version but also they're like I
don't understand any of this now they're
kind of like period pieces right so like
I think the dope thing about reading
books is you're able to like put
yourself in that time to kind of
understand the space and then now like
the any type of like tension or anything
like that it's like you you can't it's
like it'd be like imagine like you take
all context clues out of [__]
Inglorious Bastards right and you're
like I don't get why [__] Jews and
Germans are even beefing
[Laughter]
and then she had to apologize for it wow
so I mean that's Bart's just citing
Whoopi Goldberg by the way yeah because
books are literal time machines yeah
they start erasing parts of it we're not
gonna build a time it's a weird revision
of History where instead of just showing
how it was back then and studying that
it's more like let's make it more
palatable yeah we can't forget our
history that's what's weird is that like
nowadays it's like less and less that
people should be educated on how to
receive info yeah now it's like no let's
make it easy like let's go to the bottom
idiot yeah and they're like revising
everything to where it's weird because
like so people don't like it that we
were taught about Christopher Columbus
in such a like PC way to the point where
when we grew up we got the wrong history
of what he actually did right so then
if everyone's going to sugarcoat
everything and like make it so peaceful
and loving and woken or whatever then
that means that we actually don't get
the accurate way right how things used
to be yeah yeah and then we let it slide
more yeah you know if you talk about
countries like certain countries like oh
well they were known for this and then
if you like whitewash it or you you PC
eyes it or whatever then when they start
to do it again no one can be like oh
well they've been doing this to be fair
though I mean human history has
constantly shown that we constantly
erase human history yeah for real and we
can't do that [__] we can't do that [__]
we don't remember our history
[Music]
foreign